okay here we have Josh josh is you know
we all have a soft spot for Josh he had
just recently lost well over a hundred
pounds and I thought he looks so good he
has such a handsome look to him he's got
this wavy curly hair he's got this kind
of thick beard he is a bit burton that
is his body shape and you know we wanted
to celebrate his shape as well as
enhance it so the first thing we wanted
to do is tell him that he ties his ties
way too short and the fact that maybe he
doesn't need to wear a belt maybe he
should wear a suit jacket that doesn't
really facilitate a belt and maybe he
doesn't also need to wear a totally
white shirt so we decided to put him in
a suit that was his appropriate size he
said he didn't really know his size so
we told him what his size was we put him
in this beautiful suit supply suit it
had kind of a medium width lapel it had
the perfect button stance which was kind
of hit him midway on his torso a
slimming pair of pants that weren't too
tight we really worked on the shirt with
high combination to be harmonious with
the suit so he's wearing this really
modern mix of like a deep gray suit with
a pale gray shirt remember what I said
earlier not to wear the white shirt as a
larger guy it's really important to
think about some medium tone colors now
I don't want you to think you've to go
out buy a black suit because maybe you
have a little bit of a of a belly or
you're not the perfect v-shape but I
think these mid tones like what we put
Josh in which is this kind of this
graphite gray just works so well with
his complexion but also with his body
type so stay away from super dark colors
stay away from light colors and stay
away from patterns of any kind
you